uh but we begin with new information
this morning about the unprecedented fbi
search of mar-a-lago former president
trump had nothing to say just a thumbs
up after meeting with a dozen
conservative house republicans last
night at his golf club in bedminster new
jersey sources tell cbs news the search
warrant is part of an investigation into
classified material that was taken by
the former president mr trump calls it a
quote coordinated attack
chief washington correspondent major
garrett is outside mar-a-lago with new
details about the fbi's search major
good morning
good morning nancy good morning everyone
a trump attorney president at the time
tells us the fbi search targeted three
rooms at mar-a-lago the president's
bedroom his office and a storage room
the fbi agents were terse but
professional the attorney told us now
the justice department has yet to
publicly explain the evidentiary basis
for this fbi raid or what laws may have
been broken but trump supporters we met
here have filled this vacuum of
information on their own with loyalty
and anger
former president trump supporters
banners flying and horns blaring
are rallying to his defense and
deepening their suspicions it's an
invasion of our president's prop
property and his life
and it can't stand trump loyalists see a
system out of balance multiple
investigations of trump less emphasis on
suspected democratic wrongdoing i
definitely think it was unsafe unfair
and suspicious the documents taken
monday are believed to contain
classified information trump and federal
investigators had been in negotiations
over the records and the fbi visited
mar-a-lago in june trump allies on
capitol hill questioned the timing and
called for transparency this seems to be
unnerving
dangerous ill-advised i think we need
some answers the president was not brief
did not was not aware of it the fbi
action was the first search warrant
carried out against a former president
at least two trump attorneys were there
u.s officials tell cbs news approval
came from the highest levels of the
justice department
former attorney general alberto gonzalez
described the process prosecutors took
an affidavit to a federal judge
presented information
describe the condition the location of
to be searched
probable cause conditions in terms of
kind of information
that they believe that they were going
to uncover and the judge signed off on
the warrant gonzales said the stakes
legally and politically for attorney
general merrick garland are enormous
when i was the attorney general i only
signed off on one search warrant that's
how unusual it is for the attorney
general to sign off
on these searches
it is expected later today trump will
sit for a deposition with attorneys
representing the new york state attorney
general's office this part of a
long-running civil investigation into
trump organization finances trump has
called this yet another witch hunt and
posted on social media quote my great
company and myself are being attacked
from all sides nancy
and president trump's lawyers now
suggesting without proof that perhaps
the fbi planted evidence major garrett
outside mar-a-lago thank you so much